he's Lane Kiffin Florida Atlantic
University head coach and he joins his
continental kya tire Coaches Corner
they got Oklahoma coming up Saturday at
noon eastern and coach joins us now
coach good to have you back how are you
great Dan thanks for having me why is
Florida Atlantic the Owls that's a good
question I should probably know that did
you did you schedule Oklahoma or was
that already on the books for Florida
Atlantic that was already on they do
that stuff all four or five years in
advance do you uh are you okay being
tested like this not not many you know
coaches go yeah you can't wait to go to
Oklahoma top ten team and start out my
season can you hear me
I lost their first okay not not many
coaches want to go there yeah top ten
team yeah and then I didn't hear
anything after that but I think you
would know my answer knowing me are you
okay with that you like to challenge I
love it it's awesome you something be
motivated for your players all offseason
going and play you know top five team in
the country but obviously a lot of
better better players and we have so
what a great test do you know what your
pep talk pregame speech is going to be
already I do not know yet like that kind
of comes that kind of comes to me as we
get closer you know just maybe um let's
go slow so we can kind of you know not
get beat by over 40 points type of
speech wait do you think you're gonna
get blown out honestly well I mean they
don't keep building those big buildings
in Vegas for no reason I mean people do
know what they're talking about you know
we're obviously huge underdogs in this
game so you know and just for us to be
in the game you have to be one of those
games where every single thing went
right and you got every call your way so
but that's why they schedule these games
to these bigger programs and you know
I've been I've been there where you know
by the time
the second half you play in your second
third string guys alright when you talk
to your kids you're not gonna say you
know why they had those buildings in
Vegas because the oddsmakers are always
right we're big underdogs out here let's
try to keep it close now let's go get
them I'm writing this down it doesn't
have to be a long pep talk there coach
the the difference of not having Baker
Mayfield in there in Cuyler Murray at
quarterback what what's that present for
your defense well unfortunately for us
you know collars are unbelievable
athlete we were actually at Alabama when
we played him when Rory transferred and
he did well last season when he went in
a few games but the problem with him is
you can play great defense cover
everybody then he can't tackle him you
know because he's still fast you know he
actually you know faster than Baker so
in in some ways crazy as it sounds for
the number one pick of the draft
this guy's harder to defend really way
he's a better runner I know that but a
better athlete yeah in the college and
in the college game really those runners
people went a lot with them you know
regardless you know they struggle at the
next level but College it's hard because
the way the game is officiated and the
tempo in the game you know that these
guys if you look at running quarterbacks
just look good in the second half helped
once defenses start to get tired and
they're kind of the one position that
isn't tired so I always I always say
took a second half you see those Jalen
hurts of the world those type of
quarterbacks they make huge runs in the
second half
once the defense starts wearing now are
you surprised that Nick Saban hasn't
announced who his quarterback is going
to be the starting quarterback against
Louisville because you didn't want one
to transfer the national championship
you wasn't going now it's a starter and
you're gonna play both of them in the
game do you think both of them play this
year yeah they're both gonna play in the
first game again so nobody transfers
well you you probably could have reached
out then - Jalen
Hertz he could have been a nice little
addition that's not legal is it you're
not allowed to talk to that would not be
going down I just wasn't sure that just
in case Jalen Hertz needs a place to
play Florida Atlantic and then he could
ask hey why are you guys called the Owls
and then you could accomplish two things
there what is your recruiting strategy
normally in the offseason we have a I
know every coach says this but we have a
very easy place to recruit to you have
great weather you know you live in Boca
we play a really in a wide-open
conference so there's a lot of points
being scored so defensively a lot of
stats offensively a lot of stats so and
I think that you know we put the other
the type of staff that's equal to SEC
type staff so you can come here and get
coached the same way you do there are
you calling plays this year I helped
with it
charlie weis jr. is our coordinator so
he's gonna calm most but we work
together on throughout the week just
like getting over Al's and I did last
year but how tough is that to give up
because it feels like you have a whole
lot of fun Owen plays
I know practice is really boring
[Music]
it was it was hard it was hard at first
I've got a little more used to it but I
do a lot of the work during the week so
you know you do kind of you do kind of
still feel the same on game day because
I'm the plays work you know it's stuff
that you designed and helped put in and
then make adjustments during the games
and and jump in you know at time to time
and I actually have found it helps me be
a way better head coach because now
instead of between series spending my
whole time with all kinds trying to
figure out what we're going to do you
know I'm watching the defense special
teams managing the game a lot better so
I found it to making a lot better head
coach on game day and during the week
we're talking to Lane Kiffin Florida
Atlantic University head coach he has no
chance against Oklahoma tomorrow joining
us on the Dan Patrick show how has your
profile as a head coach been enhanced or
helped by Twitter because you're very
active on Twitter
well I think in different ways I think
if for the people that matter to to me
being recruits recruits parents the
people I work for the president the
board here it's been great you know
because it draws attention to school
attention to our program which is
exactly what the president wanted us to
do when he hired us and and it's worked
out of eight applications up over forty
percent in one year which is unheard of
you know just because of the football
team so does it does it help nationally
with other ATS or presidents probably
not but that's not that's not my concern
so I know I get dinged for it but I
always look is I'm doing it right
instead of doing it the other way around
and just trying to please other people I
don't work for and just say the right
thing all the time
well I it's fun but I think it makes you
feel or sound younger and you're not
trying to appeal to the president's and
athletic directors you're appealing to
your kids eighteen year old kids at
least that is what I think the strategy
is you walk into you walk into a home
you know and and the kid and the parents
do you know hey we love your Twitter we
follow you on twitter a and starts
conversations about different things and
stuff and so you know I see it actually
helped us in recruiting not that you
ever leave Florida Atlantic but the
least likely destination of places that
you had been at before USC Raiders
Alabama I I guess I could put Tennessee
in there but least likely if I was
ranking them what would the order be a
hypothetical at least likely that I
would return to yeah yeah we're butts
who's number one
Oakland because Gruden got a 10-year
contract so be like 100 years old by
then
so there's number one I really don't
[Music]
okay Tennessee actually wanted us back
last year believer on sans which we
never thought that would happen
ya know they would be the most likely
and then I won't I'll just leave the
other two in the middle when's the last
time you talked to Coach Saban not for a
while I text him stuff actually Texas on
this morning on a situation because he
said like today's his big situation
okay so anytime something new comes up
that in the three years there I've never
thought ever was on something I may draw
it up and send it to him or something
like there was a situation this morning
that I did that was but um but that's
that's him he's not he's not no matter
who you are he's now to pick up the
phone and call and you know check in you
know see how things are going or ask if
you want to you know come hang out or
something I asked him I said does your
wife he was on yesterday I said does
your wife ever remind you to have fun
and then he goes people always say that
I'm not having fun but I'm having fun
and he said it like that coach oh I know
fun is so I danced on his winning and
you hold that trophy and you take a
picture and then you hand it away and
then you go work on the next one
have you ever seen him where you where
he's like cutting loose like a couple of
beers and he's dancing or having fun no
no not really no so I there was a there
was that anonymous pole or whatever
about coaches and who you'd want to have
who do you want me to go out of beer
with and like three coaches like picnic
savings and like first off he doesn't
drink and second off well like where
would you even picture this happening
what if we went to the lake house yeah I
still don't think you okay what if we
went to Applebee's and just sat in a
booth and just had some wings or
something and just shot the breeze he's
not gonna he's not gonna let his guard
down no that's not that's not as baby
you didn't going to Applebee's I'm okay
she got tuned something's not in his
office like okay that's not scheduled
that's not scheduled with it there's
going to be a night there have to be an
itinerary an agenda of the conversation
like night an area for the conversation
at Applebee's like what are we going to
said to him two days in advance buddy he
would have an itinerary if you guys went
out and just add like a social meetings
social gathering yeah well that would
never happen okay if it did that and I'm
saying that because he's so organized in
detail that's how he is every minute of
every single day there's not like you
don't just you just didn't sit for five
minutes and like have a conversation
with you like hey what did you last
night or how are the kids like that's
not happening
there's every minute of the day there's
there's why he's so good there's zero
waste of time in his day from the second
he wakes up on me on his drive in when
he's driving and he's already calling
people about work stuff you know on his
15 minute drive in if you beat or when
you beat Oklahoma can we have the visor
from the victory game you used Biser I
gave you a beating a long time ago yeah
I got a USC you know Oregon game yeah I
got the beanie I yeah yeah because the
chants are really good of us beating out
have you ever seen their players and if
you guys have you seen ours wait till
you watch to watch the game like in the
first quarter before we're getting blown
out and just watch this jog out on the
field and watch them jog out and then
I'm you want don't worry about getting
the visor
[Laughter]
I love your strategy you're being very
coy I like it I I see where you're
coming from you know this is just like
when Boise State played Oklahoma years
ago in the I think the Fiesta Bowl when
when Boise State went out on the field
and then Oklahoma came out you would
have thought Oklahoma brought their
younger brothers their little brothers
and I thought Boise State had no chance
in that game and they of course pulled
off the surprise so there's always that
chance coach that's why we play the game
I guess so I feel like a team like I
feel like a team like when you like to
play up a level like did you like ran
out of teams and you're like conference
looks like you're the seven-year-old you
have to go play that one gamers to ten
year olds you know you know like oh boy
when you look across ER that's what it's
gonna feel like well have fun in Norman
as only you can we always appreciate
your time coach thank you man does he he
can inspire you if you're one of his
players I would love to hear that pep
talk I wonder if he's sort of
self-deprecating with his his team yes
14 it's so refreshing to see the Vegas
eyes you see when we come down with the
Vegas odds Continental Tire Coaches
Corner
brings us Lane Kiffin gotten an entire
proud supporter of the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive what do you
drive how you drive continental designs
tires for what you do for more
information visit Continental Tire com
Continental Tire for what you do for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]